Between Guardians of the Galaxy, Avengers:
Infinity War, and Avengers: Endgame, just
about everyone on the planet has gotten a
look at Josh Brolin as Thanos.
But how they'd pull the transformation off?
Let's take a deep dive into how the MCU turned
Josh Brolin into the Mad Titan.
According to the visual effects supervisor
Kelly Port, whose company Digital Domain worked
on creating Thanos for Infinity War, the number
of people it takes to complete a major studio
movie's visual effects has exploded in recent
decades.
Marvel's own Iron Man 3 has over 1,800 people
credited in its visual effects department
alone — a dramatic step up from the special
effects-heavy blockbusters of decades past.
Port said to The Verge,
"We were reflecting back on Titanic days,
the late '90s, where a big effects film would
be considered around 300 shots.
Whereas [Infinity War], in contrast, has over
3,000 visual effects shots."
"And now, it's here.
Or should I say, 'I am.'"
Speaking in an interview with Art of VFX,
Marvels Studios' overall VFX supervisor Dan
gave some insight into the amount of work
that goes into a movie's visual effects before
anyone's even powered on their editing rig.
Speaking of Avengers: Infinity War, DeLeeuw
said,
"This movie wasn't grounded like Winter Soldier
or Civil War.
It involved eight to ten foot tall aliens
and battles on other planets.
We knew the movie was going to be massive
and had to plan accordingly."
The company's plan, according to DeLeeuw,
involved
"[dividing up] the movie into individual sequences
that would be awarded to separate VFX houses.
Each house would get a sequence that would
tell a complete narrative.
This way each house could maintain the look
and feel of the sequence while minimizing
the need for shared shots."
The responsibility of introducing Thanos to
the world in Infinity War was shouldered by
Digital Domain, which took on a workload of
513 shots amounting to over 40 minutes of
screen time.
Their work involved bringing Thanos to life
in every scene except the one on Titan, a
sequence which was instead handled by WETA
Digital.
While you might not have heard of the studios
by name before, you're certainly familiar
with their work.
WETA is the studio behind The Lord of the
Rings' Gollum and the new Planet of the Apes
movies' Caesar, while Digital Domain been
working in movies since James Cameron's True
Lies in 1994.
Founded by Cameron and acclaimed special effects
artist Stan Winston, Digital Domain has been
working on large-scale superhero movies since
X-Men in 2000, and have since had a hand in
making the first Thor, the third Iron Man,
Spider-Man: Homecoming, and Thor: Ragnarok
with Marvel Studios.
Even with the team's extensive experience,
it took over 340 people from the company nearly
two years to bring just most of Thanos' parts
to fruition, which really puts things into
perspective when it comes to how much pure
labor it takes to make movies of this scale
work.
Directors Anthony and Joe Russo met with Brolin
and the digital effects artists several months
before live shooting began, to both see what
Marvel wanted to accomplish with the character,
and also to determine what the effects companies
would be capable of turning in.
Digital Domain's Kelly Port said it was a
proud moment to show off Digital Domain's
first Thanos test to Brolin and the directors
on the actor's first day of shooting.
Port said,
"They were all very excited about it, and
I think there was a collective sigh of relief
that we could pull this off."
The results of Digital Domain's first test
were encouraging, showing that the company's
artists were capable of maintaining Brolin's
humanity as they encased his performance in
a virtual skin.
"It's just the way it is.
I'm just a messenger."
According to Dan DeLeeuw,
"The early test [showed] how much we could
do with the character.
It showed that would could take exactly what
Brolin did on stage and reproduce it with
the CG character."
The test put Brolin at ease, letting the actor
know he didn't need to oversell his performance
to make the character feel alive.
As Kelly Port put it,
"I think what was really great about his reaction
was his sense that he did not, as an actor,
need to overplay the acting."
Seeing that the effects team would be able
to effectively translate a lower-key Thanos
performance in all of its subtleties was a
boon to the filmmakers — especially Brolin,
who was worried about how he would come off
in a motion-capture performance.
No one was more nervous about bringing Thanos
to life than Josh Brolin.
Playing the Mad Titan wasn't as physically
demanding as his live-action performance as
Cable in Deadpool 2, but it was emotionally
draining.
As Brolin described it,
"I was more nervous doing that than I've been
for a long time."
While shooting the movie, Brolin at times
found himself having a hard time striking
an imposing presence while wearing an unflattering
motion capture suit.
Brolin said,
"You've got to walk around in a onesie and
imagine yourself as an actor with some impact.
[...] I'm sitting there and I'm looking like
I look, which is not 700 pounds, and purple,
and eight feet tall."
To record Brolin's performance, the production
installed motion-capture cameras all around
the movies' sets, allowing other actors more
space to interact with him.
The movements of his body were recorded by
those cameras, while close-up shots were recorded
by HD cameras that were attached to a helmet
and pointed back at his face.
All of the footage was then put into a massive
database, with every tiny movement of Brolin's
face being used for reference when it came
time to replace his features with the computer-generated
Thanos model.
The goal, according to Kelly Port, was to
have the CG model match the emotions of the
real-life actor.
Port said,
"We look at the result; you look at Brolin
side by side with Thanos.
Is he conveying the same emotional expression?
Is he conveying the same emotion with his
face?
And we make a subjective call."
One of the more interesting hurdles to overcome
in bringing Thanos to life wasn't making sure
that he looked like Josh Brolin, but rather
making sure that he looked like… well, himself.
Fans of the MCU have been anticipating Thanos'
arrival ever since the end of The Avengers
in 2012, when the big purple space monster
first turned to the camera with a sinister
grin.
This was years before Brolin was ever cast
or considered for the part in Infinity War,
so how did the pre-existing Thanos from prior
movies fit into the character's final form?
According to Port, the Digital Domain team
started their Thanos' modeling with the old
look, and slowly incorporated Brolin's features.
There was no magic to the process — just
a long back and forth between their teams
and the people at Marvel.
Port said.
"We tried to find that balance, but we did
introduce more of Brolin I think than in previous
Thanoses in the films."
The effects teams' efforts weren't immediately
met with enthusiasm.
Upon the release of the first footage of Brolin
as Thanos, many fans criticized the new look,
finding that too much had changed between
the initial and final versions.
The most difficult aspect of bringing Thanos
to life had to do with his quiet, reflective
moments.
While an effects-heavy battle scene has lots
of moving parts from a VFX perspective, it's
also easier to cut corners when the screen
is so busy with meteors, explosions, and Spider-Man
antics.
In other words, it's not that hard to make
the purple space man fight the big green guy.
It's much harder to make you believe the purple
space man can cry.
Speaking with Art of VFX, Kelly Port said
the most complicated Thanos scene is his sacrifice
of Gamora on Vormir.
Port said,
"Many of the shots of Thanos in this sequence
are very close and very emotional, so it was
extremely important that Brolin's performance
come through for this scene."
The importance of nailing Thanos' ability
to physically convey emotion can't be overstated.
One false move, and the filmmakers fall directly
into the uncanny valley.
Once you remember you're looking at something
made in a computer, it's easy to be taken
out of the story.
You'd basically be watching Jar-Jar Binks
cry — and there's nothing engrossing about
that.
"How rude."
While the idea of getting into such a pivotal
mo-cap role was daunting, Brolin has since
gone on to call Thanos, quote, "one of the
most favorite jobs I've ever had."
Part of getting into the character involved
immersing himself in nearly 50 years' worth
of Marvel Comics history.
Of course, Marvel Studios didn't just send
Brolin to the local comic book shop with a
gift card.
According to Brolin,
"They sent me over this bible, just all this
information.
It was a massive thing, and yet even that
was maybe a sixteenth of what there was to
learn."
As anyone who's ever read comic books is well
aware, the internal consistency of the characters
and their stories can sometimes be a nightmare,
especially as characters mutate across decades
under different writers.
"The comic book and Marvel world is not only
extremely emotional to people, but so in-depth.
There's no way to learn it all.
But you try to do what you can [...] I started
reading and I was in awe."
The cliche goes that eyes are windows to the
soul, which is really just a way of saying
they convey subtlety.
They squint or widen to show fear, shock,
or focus, conveying emotion through tiny microexpressions
— and when it comes to a monstrously evil
figure like Thanos, seeing those emotions
can make all the difference.
According to Anthony Russo, who co-directed
Infinity War and Endgame,
"Even though he's despicable on so many levels,
there's a part of Thanos that is very empathetic.
He has a very complex inner life, and he's
not all bad."
The filmmaker also called Josh Brolin,
"...a performer who's capable of delivering
that kind of complexity, where you have that
level of violence in him, but at the same
time you have that level of sensitivity."
All of Brolin's acting work would be for nothing
if Digital Domain proved incapable of mapping
Brolin's face onto a monster — but fortunately,
the studio was up to the task.
According to Port,
"What we really focus on is the eyes at Digital
Domain, and there's a ton of work, and a huge
amount of detail around that."
The company doesn't treat the eye as one object,
but rather as layers of intersecting objects,
making the final product feel more complex
and alive.
All of this goes a long way toward making
Thanos feel like a real person — and that
realism, in turn, makes him so much scarier.
Another one of the tricky parts of animating
a CGI character has to do with making the
audience believe the character actually exists
on the same plane as real actors.
The most important element to focus on in
this aspect is lighting.
According to Port,
"If the lighting is not good, it won't look
photoreal."
A CGI character starts off being lit by nothing.
When the character is placed into real-world
footage that is saturated with a certain kind
of lighting, a lack of similar lighting on
the CGI model will look disastrous.
Speaking to Art of VFX, Port said,
"As we began to experiment with lighting ideas,
we soon discovered that Thanos looked his
best with slightly more complex lighting with
various colors rather than monochromatic light."
Many of the scenes Digital Domain was tasked
with took place in darker settings, on spaceships
or stormy planets, giving the team some flexibility
when it came to lighting Thanos' skin.
For the scene when Thanos arrives on Earth
in broad daylight, they had to contend with
making him look like he was being lit by the
same sunshine as the performers.
Port said,
"[We] found that having Thanos walk through
the dappled light of the trees was very effective
for integrating him into the shot and giving
him depth."
The years of work paid off with Infinity War's
debut.
During an interview conducted after the movie's
release, Port said,
"The excitement of the audience's reaction
seeing the film for the first time was really,
really cool for me.
We do it for the love of the craft, but we
also do it for the love of entertaining.
The reception from the audience is so rewarding.
It means a lot."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.